good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy monday
last week we said something on
television that the usual chorus of
hyper-aggressive liars is now pretending
was somehow highly controversial
ordinarily we'd ignore all of this once
you've been denounced as a white
supremacist for quoting martin luther
king you realize none of it's real
it's all another form of social control
honestly who cares what they think
but in this one case we thought it might
be worth pausing to
restate the original point both because
it was true and therefore worth saying
and also because america badly needs a
national conversation about it
on thursday our friend mark stein guest
hosted the 7 pm hour here on fox
he did a segment on how federal
authorities are allowing illegal aliens
to fly without id
something that in case you haven't
noticed you are not permitted to do
the following exchange took place in
response to that story
we're going to play the entire clip so
you can be certain we're not leaving out
context
here it is i'm laughing because this is
one of about 10 stories that i know
you've covered
um where the government shows preference
to people who have shown
absolute contempt for our customs our
laws
our system itself and they're being
treated better than american citizens
now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest
the democratic party is trying to
replace the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world
but they become hysterical because
that's that's what's happening actually
let's just say it that's
true if look if this was happening in
your house if you were in sixth grade
for example
and without telling you your kid your
parents adopted a bunch of new siblings
and gave them brand new bikes and let
them stay up later and help them with
their homework and gave them twice the
allowance
that they gave you you would say to your
siblings you know i think we're being
replaced by
by kids that our parents love more and
it'd be kind of hard to argue against
you because
look at the evidence so this matters on
a bunch of different levels but on the
most basic level it's a voting rights
question
in a democracy one person equals one
vote if you change the population you
dilute
the political power of the people who
live there so
every time they import a new voter i
become
disenfranchised as a current voter so i
don't understand why you don't
understand this i mean everyone wants to
make a racial issue out of it oh the you
know white replacement there no no
this is a voting rights question i have
less
political power because they're
importing a brand new electorate
why should i sit back and take that the
power that i have as an american
guaranteed at birth
is one man one vote and they're diluting
it no they're not allowed to do that
why are we putting up with this
so it's a political question obviously
at least one prediction came true right
away all those little gatekeepers on
twitter did become hysterical
they spent the last four days jumping up
and down furiously trying once again to
pull the show off the air
once again they will fail though it is
amusing to see them keep at it they get
so enraged it's a riot but why all the
anger
if someone says something you think is
wrong is your first instinct to hurt
them
probably not normal people don't respond
that way
if you hear something you think is
incorrect you try to correct it
but getting the facts right is hardly
the point of this exercise the point
is to prevent unauthorized conversations
from starting in the first place
shut up racist no more questions you've
heard that before
you wonder how much longer they imagine
americans are going to go along with
this an entire country forced to lie
about everything all the time
it can't go on forever but you can see
why they're trying it
demographic change is the key to the
democratic party's political ambitions
let's say that again for emphasis
because it is the secret to the entire
immigration debate
demographic change is the key to the
democratic party's political ambitions
in order to win and maintain power
democrats plan to change the population
of the country
they're no longer trying to win you over
with their program
they're obviously not trying to improve
your life they don't even really care
about
your vote anymore their goal is to make
you irrelevant
that is provably true and because it's
true it drives them absolutely crazy
when you say it out loud a hurt dog
barks
they scream about how noting the obvious
is immoral you're a racist if you dare
to repeat
things that they themselves proudly say
most people go along with this absurd
standard
they dutifully shut up they don't think
they have a choice but no matter
what they're allowed to say in public
everyone understands the truth
when you change who votes you change who
wins
that fact has nothing inherently to do
with race or nationality
it's the nature of democracy it is
always true
you can watch it happen you probably
have all across the country we have seen
huge changes in election outcomes caused
by demographic change
new people move in and they vote
differently as a practical matter it
doesn't matter what they look like or
where they're from
even all that matters is that they have
different political views
this is every bit as true and the
migrants come from brookline as when
they come from oaxaca
in vermont white liberals fleeing the
mess they made in new york
turned the state blue as recently as
1992 vermont was reliably republican
hard to believe as that is
vermont is now a parody of lifestyle
liberalism that's demographic change at
work
you see the same thing happening in the
state of new hampshire as refugees from
massachusetts flood
north and bring their bad habits with
them montana idaho nevada all face
similar problems
the affluent liberals who wrecks
california aren't sticking around to see
how that ends
they're running to the pallid hideaways
of boise and bozeman
distorting local culture and real estate
markets as they do it
pretty soon people who were born in the
mountain west won't be able to live
there
they'll be yes replaced by private
equity barons yoga instructors and
senior vice presidents from google
beautiful places are always in danger of
being overrun by the worst people
ask anyone who grew up in aspen but in
most of this country it is immigration
from other nations more than anything
else that has driven political
transformation
and this is different from what we've
seen in vermont americans have every
right to move to new states if they want
even if they have silly political
opinions
but our leaders have no right to
encourage foreigners to move to this
country in order to change
election results doing that is an attack
on our democracy yet for decades our
leaders have done just that and they
keep doing it and they keep doing it
because it works
consider virginia the counties across
the river from washington dc now contain
one of the largest immigrant communities
in the united states
most these immigrants are hard-working
and decent people many have been very
successful in business good for them
but they also have very different
politics from the people who used to
live there
their votes have allowed democrats to
seize control of the entire state and
change it into something unrecognizable
governor blackface clan robes in
richmond owes his job to immigrants in
arlington and falls church
similar trends are now underway in
georgia and north carolina and many
other states
mass immigration increases the power of
the democratic party
period that's the reason democrats
support it
it's the only reason if 200 000
immigrants from poland showed up at our
southern border tomorrow
kamala harris wouldn't promise them
health care why simple
polls tend to vote republican that's the
difference
democrats would deport those migrants
immediately
no more hand-wringing about how we're a
nation of immigrants
hundreds of thousands of likely
republicans massing in tijuana that
would qualify as a national crisis
we'd have a border wall by wednesday for
democrats the point of immigration is
not to show compassion to refugees much
less to improve
our country it's definitely not about
racial justice
mass immigration hurts african americans
maybe more than anyone else
immigration is a means to electoral
advantage
it is about power more democratic voters
mean more power for democratic
politicians
that's the signature lesson of the state
of california
between 1948 and 1992 the state of
california voted for exactly
one democratic presidential candidate
one alone among america's big population
centers in vivid contrast to chicago and
new york
california was reliably proudly
republican
for eight years no less a figure than
ronald reagan ran the state
california the country's best schools
the best infrastructure the best economy
not to mention the prettiest natural
environment on the planet
california is a model for the world in
1980 ronald reagan its former governor
became
president of the united states in
retrospect it never got any better for
california
midway through his second term reagan
signed something called the immigration
reform and control act of 1986
though we didn't likely realize it at
the time that law made
future ronald reagan's impossible the
immigration reform and control act
brought about an amnesty and a path to
citizenship
for nearly 3 million foreign nationals
living in the u.s illegally
the next year by executive order reagan
added to that number
he halted the deportation of another
hundred thousand illegal miners the
dreamers of his day
the rest of the world watched carefully
as this happened would-be migrants
everywhere concluded that there was
no real penalty for breaking america's
laws
in fact there was a reward reagan also
signed a law that required hospitals to
provide
free medical care regardless of
immigration status the supreme court had
already guaranteed free education to
anyone who showed up without a visa
so free hospitals free schools
amnesty if you get caught why wouldn't
the rest of the world come
they soon did if you're ever bored go
back and read the coverage of the 1986
amnesty bill the day it passed
everyone at the time in both parties in
the media
assured americans that the new law would
control our border
it was called the immigration control
act after all the opposite happened
huge new waves of migrants arrived
immediately many of them
illegal california was transformed
virtually overnight
it became a democratic state in 1988
george h.w bush narrowly won california
in the presidential election
no republican has won that state since
no republican ever
will win in california not in our
lifetimes
there are now about twice as many
registered democrats in california as
there are republicans
how'd that happen there's not much
debate about it
the counties in california with the
highest percentage of republicans are
not coincidentally those with the lowest
percentage of immigrants and vice versa
california changed because the
population
changed analysis for example the 2012
presidential election
show that if you were actually from
there if you lived in the state of
california in 1980
you probably still voted republican your
views hadn't really changed
but as your state swelled with foreign
voters your views
became irrelevant your political power
the power to control your own life
disappeared with the arrival of new
people who deluded your vote
and that was the whole point that's not
democracy
it's cheating imagine watching a
football game where one team decides to
start the third quarter with an extra 40
players on the field
would you consider that fair play the
democratic party did something very much
like that in the state of california
they rigged the game with more people
they packed the electorate
as a result americans who grew up in
california lost their most basic right
in a democracy which is the right to
have their votes count
this was true for all native born
americans by the way not just
republicans
los angeles now is the largest latin
american population outside mexico city
whites are less than 30 percent of the
population they're down for more than 90
in 1960 but a less noticed decline has
occurred
among african americans according to
demographer joel cotkin in the last 30
years the proportion of black residents
in los angeles
has dropped by half the city of san
francisco is now just
5 black in 1980 it was 13
now you've heard a lot lately about the
necessity of black political power
in california that power is evaporating
due to mass immigration democratic
leaders never mention this trend but
it's obvious to the people who live
there
one poll found that almost 60 percent of
black people in california would very
much like to leave
many already have the exodus of
american-born californians of every
color began
shortly after the 1986 amnesty it has
grown to a panic rush
as you know it can now cost you five
times as much to drive a u-haul
out of california than to drive a u-haul
in that's supply and demand at work
not many americans are moving to los
angeles
yet for every californian who abandons
the state several
other people arrive from foreign
countries and that's why since 1990 the
total population of california
has grown by 10 million people that's
the equivalent of an
entirely new michigan and north carolina
in just 30 years
it's an awful lot of people in a very
short period of time
most of these new arrivals come from
poor places their standard of living
rises once they get to california
the state however has become much poorer
in 1986 california was the richest land
mass of its size
in the world california now has more
poor people than any state in the
country
as of this year according to the best
measurements available from the federal
government
california has a higher poverty rate
than mississippi
it's at the highest in the nation how
did this happen
in a healthy country one that prized
honesty and free inquiry and legitimate
social science
we would be asking that question
urgently how did a place as idyllic as
california
become so miserable that huge numbers of
people who were born there decided to
abandon their homes and flee
if you cared about the united states you
would want to know the answer
you'd want to make absolutely certain it
didn't happen anywhere else
yet the democratic party is working to
make certain it happens everywhere else
that's not a slur it's not a guess we
know it
because they brag about it constantly
the left becomes
unhinged if you point out that american
voters are being replaced by democratic
party loyalists from other countries
you're absolutely not allowed to say
that but they're allowed to say that and
they do
they say it all the time they've done
studies on it written long books about
it talked about it endlessly on
television
often in the ugliest racial terms
they're not ashamed at all
they don't think they have to be ashamed
in the fall of 2018 a columnist for the
new york times wrote a piece that was
literally entitled we can replace them
in case you wondered who the them was
the column told you explicitly
thanks to demographic change the author
noted with hearty approval
the state of georgia will soon be
controlled by democrats quote
the potential is there georgia is less
than 53 non-hispanic white
end quote again that's a new york times
columnist it's not some
q anon blogger they tell you that
demographic replacement
is an obsession on the right no it's not
they say it's some horrifying right-wing
conspiracy theory the red is obsessed
with it
no the left is obsessed with it in fact
it's the central idea of the modern
democratic party
demographic replacement is their
obsession
because it's their path to power several
years ago future obama cabinet sector
secretary julian castro went on cbs to
explain why texas will soon be a
democratic state
in a couple of presidential cycles
you'll be on election night
you'll be announcing that we're calling
the 38 electoral votes of texas for the
democratic nominee for president
it's changing it's going to become a
purple state and then a blue state
because of the demographics because of
the population growth of folks from
outside of texas
no one attacked julian castro for saying
that no one asked who these quote
folks from outside texas might be or why
they had a right to control the future
of people who already lived in texas
nobody said a word about it it seemed
normal
it was normal it still is normal in
washington what qualifies as shocking
is any real attempt to protect democracy
in the summer of 2019 then president
donald trump promised falsely as it
turned out
that he was going to deport huge numbers
of foreign nationals living here
illegally
kamala harris's response to this was
revealing
harris could have argued as democrats
often do argue that deportation is cruel
and it's un-american
but she didn't say that instead she told
the truth about it quote
let's call this what it is harris wrote
on twitter it's an attempt to remake the
demographics of our country by cracking
down on
immigrants that this threat is coming
from the president of the united states
is deeply reprehensible and an affront
to our values
we will fight this but wait a second
donald trump has announced had announced
he was deporting illegal aliens
illegal aliens aren't allowed to vote in
our elections they're not even allowed
to live here
how is sending them home to their own
countries quote an attempt to remake the
demographics of our country
illegal aliens shouldn't even count in
the demographics of our country they're
not americans
kamala harris's response only makes
sense
if you believe that the millions of
foreigners breaking our laws to live
here
are future democratic voters and that's
exactly what kamala harris does believe
it's shocking if you think about it and
that's why you're not allowed to think
about it
thinking about what kamala harris is
planning kamel harris herself would like
you to know
is deeply reprehensible and affront to
our values in other words
submit to our scheme or your immoral
if you heard prominent people talk like
this in any other country you'd be
confused
a nation's leadership class admitting
they hoped to replace their own citizens
it seems grotesque
if you believed in democracy you would
work to protect the potency
of every citizen's vote obviously you
wonder if people even debate questions
like this in countries that don't hate
themselves
countries like japan or south korea or
israel
go to the anti-defamation league's
website sometime if you'd like a glimpse
of what an unvarnished conversation
about a country's national interest
might look like in a short essay posted
to the site the adl explains why the
state of israel should not allow more
arabs to become citizens with voting
rights quote
with historically high birth rates among
the palestinians and a possible influx
of palestinian refugees and their
descendants now living around the world
the adl explains jews would quickly
become a minority within a binational
state
thus likely ending any semblance of
equal representation and protections
in this situation the jewish population
would be increasingly politically and
potentially physically vulnerable
it is unrealistic and unacceptable the
adl continues
to expect the state of israel to
voluntarily subvert its own sovereign
existence and nationalist identity
and become a vulnerable minority within
what was once its own territory
end quote now from israel's perspective
this makes perfect sense why would
any democratic nation make its own
citizens
less powerful isn't that the deepest
betrayal of all
in the words of the adl why would a
government subvert its own sovereign
existence
good question maybe adl president
jonathan greenblatt will join us
sometime to explain
and tell us whether that same principle
applies to the united states
most americans believe it does
unfortunately most americans don't have
a say in the matter
most americans aren't even allowed to
have the conversation
so they watch from the sidelines as
their democracy is murdered by people
who claim to be its defenders
democracy democracy democracy screams
the twitter mob
even as the votes of the people who were
born here
declined steadily in value deluded and
increasingly worthless like the us
dollar
this is what it looks like when an
entire native population
black and white but every one of them an
american
is systematically disenfranchised middle
class americans become less powerful
every year
they have less economic power and thanks
to mass immigration
they now have less political power the
leaders making these changes have no
sympathy for their victims
they blame the country for its own
suffering you always hate the people you
hurt
that's all true every honest person
knows that it's true as long as we're
here we're going to keep saying it out
loud